my dad has been attacked by a shark
twice in the same area he keeps swimming
um in the same area the first time that
he was attacked because I have uh
rehabbing he would say that it wasn't
the shark's fault he was just doing what
he was supposed to do okay and he would
go back to the same spot even after
rehability rehabilitating his his uh
muscles and doing all this stuff he'd go
back
um and then he was attacked within two
weeks of being in that spot again
and um the second time he went back
after two months and he's attacked again
same spot he won't switch up his
swimming spot I'm trying to get him to
do that he won't
um me and my sisters and my mom have
told him that even though the nature of
a shark is to attack and eat and do what
it's supposed to do you still shouldn't
put yourself in that position in the
same spot we're trying to get removed on
the beach through different spot he
won't do it
I'm hoping you guys will uh like
reiterate our point and just tell him
like
no matter how many times you go back to
the same spot no matter how many times
you rehab the shark's still going to do
what the shark does and you need to move
your swimming spot dad the response of
Dad you need to stop going in there like
you get attacked by a shark and your
dad's responsive well the shark's just
doing what the shark is supposed to do
is the same as this you say pretend I'm
the dad and you say okay yeah uh sharks
is doing what's wait no you say you got
to swim somewhere else like what he's
saying oh yeah you can't swim with
yourself you gotta swim somewhere else
man shark's there
trucks are usually uh blue or gray
it's the it's a non response it's not a
[__] response right yeah what about
it do with anything yeah yeah shark's
gonna do what the shark's gonna do so
this guy's dad
uh answers questions with non-answers
and that should be highlighted next time
he says that stupid answer wrong
okay yeah so don't let him say that
because that is a non-answer
uh
it's good I guess to have some kind of
sense of exposure therapy but it's not
that he's scared he's not like I'm
scared I need to face my fears and go
back yeah this guy's like an idiot
version of Captain Ahab you know what I
mean I gotta goes that he's the guy who
tries to kill Moby Dick and he always
gets attacked by it but keeps going I
know he's the main character or not
really the main character I know he's
the captain of the [__] the whale's a
character constantly trying to kill Moby
Dick dude I don't
you know like mangled him and ravaged
his body but he keeps going back because
it's his you know it's my white whale
that's like what that means no I don't
know you lived in the world you ever
lived in the world you ever lived in the
world with people my white whale dude I
like that yeah it's cool that's really
nice it's like The elusive thing that
you always want yep yep yep this is the
shark's Place yep and you know this now
because of twice this happened once
maybe it could have been a mistake maybe
or the shirt you're like hey what's
going on is that a seal ah [__] it freak
accident but now this you know the
shark's like get out of my [__] place
yeah it's basically like hey like if
you're with a group of people and you're
like let's go to the park and throw the
ball around yeah uh and someone's like I
don't I'd rather not go to the park
let's go into a guy's house and throw
the ball like yeah well you don't do
that because somebody's gonna get really
mad at you because you're in their
property and they're gonna probably
shoot you here's another thing too if
you're let's go to the park and put a
frisbee around yep yeah but there's a
lion there you you wouldn't go that you
would go to a different part this guy
sick like it's wrong a park belongs to
us more than the ocean and you're being
like this about the ocean yeah yeah so
it's almost like I have a question does
he want to die bro what's what he might
want to die what's wrong with me I keep
I spelled I mean you might as well keep
going you know yeah well he might want
to die yeah people have a weird thing
like that like they're like
people have a weird thing with that kind
of stuff death you know they secretly
want it you know yeah the Death Drive
dude the Death Drive the Death Drive is
that something yeah is that something
like the white whale well similar but
it's it's if if you're saying is it like
the white one in the sense that someone
long ago wrote about it yes I never
heard about the death drive that's right
it's like this the sex drive but it's
like uh oh you are born and then you are
immediately sort of the Allure of death
is very strong that you are seeking it
in indirect ways uh sometimes not so
indirect usually latent ways
okay you good yeah I don't think I have
that I don't want to die no but I mean
people I think people don't realize that
the point is that it's it's late they
don't realize that they have it but
they're just throwing the word Layton
trying to so it's like a latency period
just learn the word late it's like a
latency wow all right situation yeah
yeah dude I mean you know you have an
intervention with your dad you know how
the shark show up maybe slap your dad in
the face no that's because sometimes it
takes like a real shaking up to really
get a point across also how about this
have you actually
have you actually had a one-on-one where
you sat with your dad or called your dad
and said hey it really worries me I know
this may be my thing maybe well I'm
asking you don't swim there yeah please
yeah have you done that that could work
that should be the last line of defense
and if you haven't done that you should
do that yes but I mean at a certain
point like
he's just being such a Titanic [__]
this guy's people who love him he likes
to go swimming he won't change his
swimming place or swimming route
whatever the hell it's killing people
tell me what to do just
like dude a shark is eating you yeah
it's weird dude
also that's so annoying when somebody's
like dude I don't bro if if a shark
bites me yeah I'm not adopting the
[__] thing where people go like
that's just what sharks do and I can't
be mad at it nature does what it does
dude I'm so pissed off at that shark
well that's you know what you're right
you do that [__] because just as much as
the shark's gonna do what it's gonna do
is right what should also be right is
that the person that the shark bites
wants to [__] kill this and I'm gonna
kill I'm gonna go I'm gonna kill it I
want to kill it that's what nature kind
of give me dude these hero type
[__] that are like you know
what that's nature I can't fault the
shark for being a shark [__] that dude
I'm so pissed off at that shark if it
bites me but that's what I'm saying if a
gazelle gets half eaten by a lion it's
not just like wow this is what Lions do
continue
you know what I'm saying yeah humans are
the only ones that are like hey that's
just nature I want to you know yeah all
animals dude you know oh well that's a
different thing I think dogs cats
rabbits wow if the rabbits were big
we'd be [__]
you ever think about that I love you
both thanks Chris you
you and and the 10 minute pot and and uh
thank you guys okay wait let me know
what you think so him
oh
Marco
I'm sorry what's going on oops
what's going on
why do you keep playing [__] music
what are you doing I'm not trying to no
[__] but you're doing it
that's just as much as a non-responsible
it doesn't even matter if I try to
explain it but
what's happening stop is what matters
okay
what's happening is
it was on there and I locked the phone
so then I opened the phone to look
something up
and it's still on nine computers there
wow look at look at about a goddamn nine
computer turn the sounds down
yeah I get it I get it it's like when I
was when I was watching porn and then I
took my uh laptop over to Starbucks and
I opened it up and it goes oh yeah
that used to happen sometimes when I
would start my car
what are you laughing at because I would
start the car like Lauren was in the car
you know Bluetooth needs to get better
with that [__] yeah don't do it don't
pull up XVideos
I was watching I don't have a safari
dude you know yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
it's always that one too the flat note
oh yeah the swallow first crazy crazy
crazy
crazy crazy congratulations